[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHET HAASE: Hello, and welcome
to What's New in Android.
Or as I, the only person, like
to refer to it as the Android
Keynote.
I'm Chet Haase from the
Android UI Toolkit team.
ROMAINE GUY: And I'm Romaine
Guy for the Graphics team.
DAN SANDLER: And I'm Dan
Sandler from the System UI team.
And we don't have a lot of
time, so let's get to it.
Are you ready for
What's New in Android?
Here's where we left
off last time, API 25.
So we're just going
to that git-sha
there, pop it in to
git-diff, and then off we go.
You're going to want
write this down.
OK--
CHET HAASE: Next.
DAN SANDLER: Yep, that
was a good one, OK.
CHET HAASE: I love those.
DAN SANDLER: Oh, man, remember
we almost made that an enum?
It was hilarious.
[LAUGHTER]
You got that?
You think this is
what people came for?
I don't know why we didn't
think of this before.
So we've been doing this
talk-- we've been telling you
what's new for years.
And you can see that--
I've forgot my blazer.
Actually, no, I had
a lovely red blazer,
but somebody borrowed
it for the keynote.
[LAUGHTER]
You've got your--
ROMAINE GUY: It looks like
you're [INAUDIBLE] me.
DAN SANDLER: [LAUGHS]
But this year it
was a little different, right?
You had developer
previews well in advance,
so you've seen a lot
of these APIs before.
You had the Google keynote
where we showed off
a lot of really exciting stuff.
We had a developer
keynote where you
learn about even
more developer stuff.
So what are we doing here?
What is the point of
What's New in Android?
CHET HAASE: Existential crisis.
DAN SANDLER: [LAUGHS] So--
did you test this clicker?
CHET HAASE: I did,
DAN SANDLER: OK.
CHET HAASE: I did.
DAN SANDLER: Think of
this talk like a wine
tasting or a whiskey flight
or one of those soda machines
that you can push
all the buttons on.
This is an artisanal
hand-picked selection of things
you may have overlooked in
the new release of Android,
things you're going to
need to do no matter
what to be part of Android
O, and honestly just
things we'd like to talk
about when we're on stage.
So with that, this is really
what's new in Android.
Specifically, what
you might have
missed in the developer
preview or the I/O
keynote or the other keynote,
and why you should care.
One last thing that I want
to make sure we get to today
is this.
Everybody's always
excited about this.
But we're going to
hold that for the end.
AUDIENCE: Awww.
DAN SANDLER: It's
going to be good.
All right, let's get started.
Romaine, talk about
UI and graphics.
ROMAINE GUY: Yes, let's start.
So the first feature
we want to talk about
is one that you saw this
morning in one of the keynotes.
Chet, this clicker
does not work.
You didn't test it.
CHET HAASE: Ah.
You know--
DAN SANDLER: Wasting time.
CHET HAASE: --you know, I'm
going to stand back here
and I'm going to do
the slides for you.
ROMAINE GUY: All right.
Go to the next slide, please.
DAN SANDLER: This
is why they didn't
want to give us a clicker.
ROMAINE GUY: All
right, so a feature--
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: That works for me.
ROMAINE GUY: Just go back there.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't want to see you.
So the first feature
that you saw this morning
in one of the keynotes, picture
in picture is not just for TV
anymore.
It's also for your phone.
So here we have an example
with third party application.
Netflix running on your
phone, picture in picture.
Give me that clicker.
DAN SANDLER: Let's move back.
There we go.
ROMAINE GUY: And
it's really easy
to implement in
your application.
You just have to
modify your manifest--
and stop playing the
animation, please.
You just have to say support
picture in picture, true.
You don't need in O
the resizeable activity
true attribute anymore,
and you should also
test configuration changes.
And in your code when
you want to enter
the picture in picture mode,
you just have one [INAUDIBLE]
to call.
You get your activity, and you
call enterPictureInPicture.
Super simple, and it's going
to make your user super happy.
Then a feature that's
very dear to my heart.
It's color management.
So we're adding support for
wide-gamut displacing O.
It's not going to
be on all devices.
Only devices that
support the feature
will enable it for
your application.
We're adding support
for 16 bit PNG files,
so you can have wider colors,
more saturated colors.
We support ICC profiles,
so color profiles
embedded in bitmaps in
JPEGs, PNGs, and the WebPs.
It will ensure accurate
rendition of colors
across multiple screens.
We also have a
bunch of new APIs,
but we're going
to talk about that
more at the end of the
week in a different talk.
So because a picture is
worth a thousand words,
this is color management
and how it works.
I hope it's clear.
[LAUGHTER]
But really the color
management is about something
you've probably experienced
with your own application.
Your colors look
different across devices.
So we have solutions
for you in Android O.
So if you want to
know more, there's
going to be a talk
that I'm going to give
on Friday at 11:30 on stage 2.
It's called Understanding Color.
Next, we are also adding
support for multiple displays.
If your application is already--
the clicker is horrible.
If your application supports
multiple windows already,
the multi-window
mode, it already
supports multiple display in
O. When the phone is connected
or a network device is
connected to multiple displays
and you have an application
that's compatible,
the user can choose to
send your application
on a different display.
When this happens, you're going
to get a resizing configuration
change.
You can also control on what
display your activity shows up.
You can use the Activity
Options for that.
And you should
really test your app
if you want to
support this feature.
To help you with testing, we
have two new developer tools.
You can run adb shell
dumpsys display.
It will list all the
current available displays
on the device.
And if you call adb shell start
with your activity intent,
you can specify the
display on which
you want to start the activity.
So a very easy way
for you to test this.
There's a lot more
to those APIs,
so we encourage you to
go to the office hours
on Friday and Thursday, the
office hours for Windows
and activities.
Next, media.
[LAUGHTER]
So we have a lot of very useful
classes in our media package.
We have the media player, the
media recorder, the extractor,
and the codec.
And we added a
new getMetrics API
on every one of those classes.
It helps to query
information about the media
that you're dealing with.
So you can query the resolution,
the codec, the bitrate,
the duration, this kind of data.
It's super easy to use.
Just call getMetrics on
one of those objects.
You get the
PersistableBundle, and you
can look up the documentation
on developer.android.com
to know what kind of
queries are available.
Playback is also much improved.
You now have control over the
buffering in your application.
So you can specify a low
and a high watermark.
So the playback of
the video will not
start until you reach
the low watermark,
and the system will
do its best to keep
cache data between this
low and high watermark.
And you can specify
the watermarks
in duration or amount
of data, in size.
We also improved seeking.
So when you seek
into a video, you
can now choose the behavior.
Do you want to seek
to the closest frame,
to the next keyframe, to
the previous keyframe,
or to the closest sync frame.
And, finally, we
made DRM playback
with Widevine a
lot easier to use
in all of your applications.
For recording, until
now, the media mixer
only let you add one video
track and/or one audio track.
Now you can have as many audio
and video tracks as you want.
You can also create
custom tracks.
The MIME type has to
start with "application/"
and it's basically a side band
where you can encode any kind
of data you want.
So a canonical example is
to encode JavaScript data
if you want to be able
to replay a 360 video
or something like that.
WebView comes with
really useful new APIs.
We've added the ability
to save browsing,
that you know and
love from Chrome.
That detects malwares
and unsecure web pages.
So if you add this tag in your
manifest, this meta-data tag,
it's going to use the same
backend and the same API
that Chrome itself uses
to secure the browsing
experience for your users.
The WebView uses now
multiple processes.
And in particular,
there's a render process.
So we also have new APIs to
deal with these multi-processes.
So if the render
process crashes,
you can use the Termination
Handle API to detect the crash
and decide what to do
in your application.
You can crash your
application if you want,
you can try to
restart the WebView,
or you can just log something
and show a message to the user.
It's much more
graceful than before.
You can also use the
Renderer Importance API
to better deal with the
low memory situations.
So when the system
is low on memory,
it's going to try to
reclaim RAM from somewhere.
And you can tell the
system whether your WebView
is very important or not that
important to your application.
So if the WebView is
critical to your application,
you should definitely
take a look at this API.
CHET HAASE: So you know it's
the right button, right?
ROMAINE GUY: Yes, I know that.
[LAUGHTER]
So there were a couple of
long requested features
for animators, specifically
for AnimatorSets.
They were deceptively tricky to
implement, so it took a while.
But now in Android O, we have
the capability in AnimatorSets
of having seeking.
So now if you have
an Animator that's
a collection of
child Animators, you
can seek within
those child Animators
in the overall AnimatorSet.
So, yeah.
We also have the ability, uh--
to reverse
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAINE GUY: Hey,
Chet, didn't you
try to implement those
APIs a while ago?
CHET HAASE: Maybe.
ROMAINE GUY: Uh-huh.
And who implemented
the APIs in the end?
CHET HAASE: Not me.
ROMAINE GUY: Yeah
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
ROMAINE GUY: Exactly.
CHET HAASE: So new capability,
again, in AnimatorSet
to reverse.
So you no longer have to set up
a separate AnimatorSet with all
that functionality and get
a listener and all that.
We do all that tedious
work for you, so yeah.
Autofill, because
it's really tedious
to get all that information
correct over and over.
We saw this in the
keynote earlier.
It's the ability to--
you've got a form to fill in.
There is a provider that can
give you that information.
So when you get
those text fields,
we can automatically enter
that information for you.
And there are a couple of
different aspects to this.
One is that you can certainly
implement your own service
and provide that capability,
or depend on service
that we are providing instead.
Or more typically, you will
implement a client of that.
The standard views just work.
If you're using TextView,
if you're using EditText,
we know how to receive
this information
to interact with
a service already.
So you don't need to do
anything for standard views.
If you're using custom
views, or if you
want to provide more information
about standard views,
we have APIs for providing
hints to us about what the value
types are, as well
as APIs to tell
us more about your
custom views and how
you want to interact with that.
Also if you have a
custom view hierarchy--
let's say you have a surface
view where you have views
inside of there but all we know
is that there's a SurfaceView,
then there are APIs
for you to tell us
about the virtual hierarchy that
you want us to interact with.
There is going to be more about
this in a session on Friday
morning, so go to
that if you want
to learn more about autofill.
And now let's talk a
little bit about text.
There's been a bunch of stuff
going on in the text arena
this time.
I think we can rewrite this.
There we go.
[LAUGHTER]
I only use that font
because it hurts Dan.
It just physically hurts him.
It's awesome.
ROMAINE GUY: I
think you broke him.
CHET HAASE: All right,
so first of all,
you can use XML to declare
font information using
sort of a neat hack
with data binding,
but it's kind of tricky to do.
And why shouldn't
we actually provide
that capability for you?
So now we do.
So you can now actually
put a font file directly
in this new resource
font directory.
[APPLAUSE]
Yay, indeed.
So put that in the
directory, or you can tell us
about the font family.
So you can provide several
fonts with information
about the styles of
each, and then you
can just use those directly as
you could any other resource.
And from code, you just
say, give me that resource,
and away you go.
Downloadable fonts.
Now we have the
capability for you
to declare a font that you
want to use that we will then
download and cache on the system
for you if it is not there yet,
or if it is on the system then
we'll use it from the cache.
You can do this from
code or from XML
and use it as a resource,
just like you did in XML fonts
on the previous exciting slide.
And we also have a
font provider that we
are providing in a not yet
released version of Google Play
Services.
There is a beta version of that
available at the conference
this week.
I don't know the
details on that,
but there's a session where
you can learn the details,
or you should be able to go
to the Play Services website
to learn more about that.
And this gives you access
to all of Google fonts.
So if you just want to use
one of the standard ones,
such as that beautiful font I
use to kickoff this section,
maybe that's in there,
then you can ask for that
directly from the service.
Also there's the ability to
have Auto-Sizing TextView.
So, typically, if you
resize a TextView--
[APPLAUSE]
DAN SANDLER: You
never know what's
going to be the hit, right?
Text.
CHET HAASE: Text
is cool, especially
when it's in the right font.
So what you get now is
the behavior on the left
there where we're just
resizing the view itself.
There's no change to the font.
But on the right, if you opt
into the Auto-Sizing TextView
behavior, then we're going
to resize the font for you.
And you can specify the
behavior or the step increments
that you want to use
or the specific size
that you want to snap
to as it resizes.
So there's APIs for that.
There's APIs in both XML as well
as Java programming language
codes, so knock yourself out.
And for all of
these text features,
XML fonts, downloadable fonts,
and Auto-Sizing TextView.
They're talking about all
of these in the What's
New in Support Library
session tomorrow morning.
And you're wondering, why
are they talking about it
in a Support Library session?
Aren't these O platform APIs?
Yes, they are.
And they are also
in Support Library.
[APPLAUSE]
So you can use all of these
capabilities going back
on to earlier releases.
AccessibilityService Utilities.
If you're writing in
AccessibilityService,
great thing to do.
We have new capabilities that
you can take advantage of.
Language detection,
the ability to put
a button in the navigation bar
along with the other buttons
there to make it easier
to access your stuff.
Separate volume control
for accessibility volume,
so you're not
conflating that volume
with other volumes
on the devices,
and also the ability to define
custom fingerprint gestures.
If you want to learn
anything more about these,
there's a session this
afternoon on accessibility
that you should check out.
And finally, one of my
favorite really tiny changes--
I'm going to say
tiny because it's
one line of code for the
API, but the actual cls
that went in to fix
all the code that
was dependent upon the former
implementation was huge.
So I don't want to detract
from the work from it.
But API-wise, really
tiny, kind of hidden,
kind of looks like the same
thing from the outside.
The way findViewById used to
be declared with something
like this, public
view, findViewById,
and then you call that, you
pass in your resource ID,
and get back a view,
and then you immediately
cast it into what you want.
So TextView, you have
to tell it to TextView
on both the left and the
right, and there's parentheses,
and it's big bother.
People use helper libraries
just to get around the fact
that this looks so horrible.
So now--
[APPLAUSE]
--we have this.
I call this feature Castaway.
I think I am the only
one that does so.
DAN SANDLER: All right,
blew past my first slide.
That's fine.
I want to talk a little bit
about some of the System UI
stuff you're going to look at.
If you have an app,
you're going to need
to know about adaptive icons.
I think this got like barely
a mention in one of Steph's
slides earlier today.
Essentially, we are trying
to save you time and money.
There are so many launchers
out there, and each one of them
has a different recommendation
for the shape of your icon.
So adaptive icons is a
new piece of technology
that we have brought to you
in O that allows you to say,
here's my background, here's
my foreground, cut out
to whatever shape you like.
So even if the
launcher has a circle
or it's got round rectangle
or it's got something awful,
you have an icon that matches
exactly the local flavor.
There's going to be a
ton more information
about adaptive icons
at a talk on Thursday,
and definitely go to that one.
All right, let's talk about
shortcuts and widgets,
because launcher is
also part of System UI.
Previously, to get shortcuts and
widgets on the user's screen,
there's a broadcast for
shortcuts that kind of works,
and for widgets you just have
to beg the user, please, please,
see if you can find our
widget inside the launcher.
In O, you can now actually
request one of these things
to be pinned to the
user's workspace
using Shortcut
Manager for shortcuts,
using App Widget
Manager for widgets.
And the user then
gets the opportunity
to say, no, I don't want that
on my desktop, or yes, I do,
and, in fact, I will
go ahead and place it
exactly where I want it.
Or they can just say, sure,
find a spot for it, which
was the previous behavior.
So now you don't have to walk
the user through a long flow.
You just send them
right into this dialog.
It's super convenient.
Look at all the new users you're
going to have on your widgets.
[APPLAUSE]
I could just say I'm pausing
for applause when I'm really
fussing with the clicker here.
This also we'll talk
about on Thursday at 4:30.
All right, notifications,
you knew it was coming.
They're super useful.
They're great for engagement.
Users love them.
They may be a little
out of control.
There's a lot that is being
used in the notification stream
right now, and it's
very hard for you
to get your message to
the users that want it.
And it's very hard for a
user to manage the inflow
of demands on their attention.
If it's out of
control now, the user
should always be in control.
That's been a principle of
ours since the beginning.
We added the ability
to block notifications
from a package in Jelly Bean.
And Nougat we refined a little
bit and added quietening.
But all through this,
the number one request
we get from users is,
OK, but can I just
block some of an
app's notifications?
On the other hand,
the number one request
we get from developers
is could the user just
block some of my notifications?
It's the same thing.
Everybody's been asking
for the same thing.
And this is where notification
channels come from.
It's a new API in O.
A channel is a named
category of notifications
from one app
that all share
the same behavior.
Vibration, sound, light,
whether they pop up on screen,
so that the user has explicit
and fine grained control.
[APPLAUSE]
So it's an app, you'll get to
set up all your own channels,
defining the default behavior
for O. A private message should
pop up.
A tag maybe doesn't pop up
or it's got a lower priority,
and then it users when they
long press a notification or use
the new slide gesture
to look at it,
they can see what
channel it's on
and make changes
right there in line.
Once you target O, if you take
nothing else away from my two
minutes here, take away this.
You have to use channels
for every notification,
or they will be dropped.
So until you target O,
you can start slowly
evolving your notification
system over to channels.
Once you target O, they
have to all be channelized,
because we're trying to get
to a consistent experience
where the user knows what
they're going to get.
And we're going
to talk about that
and a lot of other
great stuff, including
design considerations,
all the code
that I didn't put up there,
whatever that little blinky
thing is over there, on
this talk at 4:30 tomorrow.
There's a lot of other great
stuff coming to System UI.
We have listed some of it here.
It ran off the end again.
I like doing that with slides.
And I encourage you very much
to check out the developer
previews or install the beta
and play with all of it.
We're really proud of it.
ROMAINE GUY: All right,
new APIs for US developers.
We expanded on the
Strict Mode API
that I'm sure you all
using in your debugging.
So now on the
ThreadPolicy, you can
get warned when using
unbuffered I/O. So if you use
an input or an output stream
without wrapping it into one
of the buffered streams,
you'll get a flash
or whatever it is, the
trigger warning you've set.
On the VmPolicy, if you
don't tag your sockets
you can also get warned.
Tagging sockets is really
useful to do traffic
debugging using Android Studio.
And finally, if you
open another intent--
if you send an intent to
outside of your application
and you need to
grant permission,
you can also be warned.
So it's fairly easy to use.
It looks like the
previous APIs we had.
Media File Access.
So we introduced the document
providers a while ago,
a couple releases ago, and
they're extremely useful,
except when you have
large documents.
If you have a
large document, you
needed to download
the entire data
before you could pass it to the
user of the document provider.
So now you can create
seekable file descriptors.
It's extremely useful
for audio, video,
or any large type of content.
It's also extremely easy to use.
So you get to StorageManager,
you open the proxy file
descriptor, you
give it a callback,
and then we're going
to invoke your callback
to request the size
of the documents,
to request some amount of
data in the byte array,
and then we're going to
tell you when to close it.
Cached data.
So this is new APIs
that the system gives
you to be a better citizen.
So each app has a
certain amount of data it
can use in the cache partition.
And when the system runs out
of space, out of storage space,
it's going to start deleting
some of your cache data.
So if you stay below the
quota that you're given,
you can avoid your
data being deleted.
For this, you can use
the StorageManager.
You can query the
number of bytes
that are allocated to your app.
You should query that
from time to time,
because the quota
can change depending
on how much of
the quote you use,
or how often the user
uses the application.
Then when you want
to allocate data,
you can just use allocateBytes.
You could do it yourself.
You could just create
a file, you could just
create an output stream.
But it's much better
to do it this way,
because when you go through
allocateBytes, if needed,
the system will delete
another app's cached data
to make space for your data.
So that means that
getCacheQuotaBytes
might be bigger than
the free space that's
left on the device.
You can also use
something called
setCacheBehaviorTombstone.
So this is very
useful for your app
to be able to tell the
difference between a file that
was never cached, and a file
that was cached but deleted.
So when you set that
behavior and the system
deletes some of your
files in your cache,
it will truncate the file.
So the file will still be there,
but the size will be set to 0.
That tells you that the cache
was deleted by the system.
And, finally, the usable space
and the allocatable space
are different.
DAN SANDLER: There's a lot
going on in Android security
in this release.
And we only have little bit
of time to talk about it.
I wanted to highlight some
of the privacy agreements
that are new in Android O.
If you've been using
Android ID, you
need to know now
that it is going
to be different for every app,
for every user on the device.
So it can't be used to
track users between apps
on the same device anymore.
Similarly, if you've
been reflecting
into system properties to get
net.hostname, it is empty now.
And so if you're
saying, well, I really
need advertising IDs to
be able to send users
the correct contextual
advertisements, that
is what the Advertising ID API
in Google Play Services is for.
So go check it out
in Google Play,
but you cannot use Android ID.
You can't trust it
anymore in the same way
you might have done.
I had a slide here
about WebView,
but then Romaine took it.
One other thing I
wanted to mention
about safe browsing in WebView
is because WebView is now
pushed to the Play
Store every six months,
you will be able to opt
into safe browsing features
as far back as Lollipop,
which is fantastic.
We also saw the unveiling
during the keynote, something
we're calling Google Play
Protect, which is actually
a lot of technologies that
we've had in place before,
but really haven't
given the visibility
that they truly deserve.
Because we are watching out
for people all the time.
So any device with Google
Play has Protect enabled.
Every app that gets
uploaded to Play
is prescreened and
continuously rescreened
for each new version
that's uploaded.
And every time
you install an app
where you have Play
Protect set up,
that app is going to
be screened as well,
even if you got it from another
store or from ADB install.
And we're really
excited about this.
There is so much
more to talk about--
so much more to talk
about in Android security.
They gave me a whole
slide deck of stuff,
so I said, why don't
you have your own talk?
I actually didn't say that,
they had their own talk anyway.
On Thursday at
2:30, you're going
to go and find out what's
new in Android security
from soup to nuts.
Everything from Kernel
hardening all the way
to more stuff about WebView.
ROMAINE GUY:
Language and runtime,
I think you already know
what I'm going to say.
So this morning, we announced
official support for Kotlin.
[APPLAUSE]
You saw Steph on stage, and
I see her sitting right there
in the hallway.
So if you see her at
I/O, go say thanks.
So Steph and the
whole team behind her
did amazing work over
the past, however
much time, to bring you this.
So go thank her.
She'll pass your thanks
along to the whole team.
So it's available
today in Android 3.0.
There's a lot of
documentation already online.
I could spend hours
talking about Kotlin
and why it's good for
you, why it's good for us.
Actually, should
I hijack the talk?
CHET HAASE: He could.
Actually, he really good.
He does, in fact.
ROMAINE GUY: But
unfortunately we
don't have that much
time in this session.
So, instead, I invite you
to come on Friday at 10:30
here on this stage.
There's going to be a talk
called Introduction to Kotlin
from Andrey Breslav, the lead
language designer at JetBrains;
and Hadi, VP of Developer
Advocacy at JetBrains.
And then in the
afternoon on stage 4,
we'll have Life is Great
and Everything Will Be OK,
Kotlin is Here by Christina
Lee from Pinterest
and Jack Wharton from Square.
[APPLAUSE]
And this is important to
us, because the reason
why we brought you Kotlin
is because you the community
are using Kotlin.
We listened, we heard you, we're
bringing you what you wanted.
So we wanted to have you, the
community, onstage to talk
about it better than we can.
Also, if you have questions,
you can come to the developer
sandbox at the Android
[INAUDIBLE] Platform
booth today from 3:00 to 4:30,
on Thursday from 2:00 to 4:00,
and on Friday from
noon to 2:00 p.m.
Andrey, the language
designer, will be there
to answer all your questions.
So please come if you want to
know anything about Kotlin.
Just go there and go
ask your questions.
Now, like Steph mentioned, we're
also doubling down on our other
languages, so the Java
programming language,
and we also have C and C++.
So for the Java
programming language,
we're adding new
packages in Android O.
We have java.time that
finally makes manipulating
time and dates easy.
And it makes sense.
It makes a lot more
sense than the older APIs
CHET HAASE: It's about time.
ROMAINE GUY: Yeah,
it's about time.
We're also bringing
you java.nio.file.
It improves on the good
old java.io.file API.
It lets you access the
attributes of the file.
It lets you easily manipulate
paths and read files.
We'll look at an example.
And, finally,
java.lang.invoke, it's
a slight variation
on reflection.
This is a gross approximation,
but it's really cool
because it lets you transform
and wrap method handles
in your application.
So here's an example
of the new files API.
So you can use the path
class to get a path.
And then you can just
call files.lines.
It will read the entire
content of the file.
You're going to get a stream.
So in this example, I'm
using lambdas and stream APIs
to remove all the empty
lines, all the lines that
start with a pound sign, and
then I collect everything back
into a single stream at the end.
So it's a lot easier
than it was before.
CHET HAASE: All right,
some changes in runtime.
We heard about some
of these this morning,
and there's more
about it this week.
New concurrent-copying
collector,
making everything basically
faster and better.
Concurrent-copying
means no pause time,
except when there is a full GC.
So it can do all
the stuff that it
needs to do in the background
while you're doing other stuff.
In particular, one of the really
cool things that it can do
is actually compact the
heap in the foreground.
So previously, I believe
in the previous release,
it had the ability to compact
the heap, which is really good.
It can defragment it, can
make the heap smaller,
it can make allocations
and collections faster,
but it could only do
this when activities
were in the background.
So it'd go into an idle
state, and then do it
when it was in that idle state.
But when it was
in the foreground,
there was nothing that it
could do about the expanding
and fragmenting heap.
Now it can collect
in the foreground,
defrag in the foreground,
and everything gets faster.
There's also a new faster
mechanism for allocations.
So we can just do bump
pointer allocations,
which is way, way faster.
Collections are
faster, and all of this
essentially results
in less jank for you.
So faster to allocate stuff,
faster to collect stuff,
means that just dealing with
garbage and memory in general
is much faster using
ART in the O release.
Lots of various optimizations,
loop unrolling, inlining.
One of the things to
note is that Dalvik
was created with memory-type
constraints, right?
Everything was
about saving memory
with Dalvik, which
means that it can only
do so much optimization.
It sort of reached
the end of its life
as far as what they could
do to optimize things.
When ART came online, they
basically put in a platform
upon which we could build
future optimization.
So we're starting to
reap those benefits now
where with every
release, including
O and future
releases, we're going
to be able to do more and more.
And there's a bunch of
them in this release.
And you should check out a
session later in the week
for more information on that.
Also there is DEX locality.
This in particular improves
launch time for activities,
because we can collect all
the memory in the same space.
So it's easier and
faster to access
as your application
is starting up.
So there's a session on Friday
morning, Performance and Memory
Improvements.
So check that out for
more particulars there.
So beyond the platform,
we have Support Library.
We have other mechanisms for
delivering things that aren't
just about the O release.
We wanted to call
out some of those.
There's the v26 beta
release that comes out
with developer preview 2.
The stuff that we already talked
about in text, fonts and XML,
downloadable fonts, as well
as Auto-Sizing TextView.
Those are all in there.
You can check those out.
In addition, there's something
that we call EmojiCompat.
So one of the big issues
that we have with emojis
is that if your
friends are sending you
emojis that are from some
future standard than whatever
we shipped on the release
that you're running,
it's not possible for
you to see those emojis.
And you're going to
see tofus instead,
which given some
of the emojis I've
seen may be more attractive,
but not very meaningful.
So wouldn't it be nice
if you could actually get
updated emojis on your device?
So now we have two
mechanisms that apps
can use to get updated emojis.
One is that apps can actually
bundle with updated emojis.
So they can update the
apps to the Play Store
and then to their
users so that the users
get more timely updates
of these emojis.
The other, and probably
better long term solution,
is to actually use
a service that we
can provide for
downloadable fonts
that we talked about earlier,
where they can automatically
get updated fonts through
downloadable fonts, right?
So the app can build
in the capability
to use the downloadable
fonts capability to have
updated emojis as we provide
them into the service.
So, again, go to the What's
New in Support Library talk
tomorrow morning to learn
more about all of those.
We also had more stuff
going on an animation
besides the small
stuff in AnimatorSet
I talked about earlier.
We have the ability to now have
physics-based animation stuff.
So if we want to see
that in animation form,
the ability to have
essentially animations
driven through velocity.
All of the animation
capabilities
that we have in the
platform to date
have been driven around
the idea of a duration.
You tell it how long
you want it to run for.
But many animations,
you really want
to drive it by the velocity.
In particular,
animations that are
driven by user interactions.
You're dragging something on
the screen and you let go,
wouldn't it be nice if it
took off from your finger
at the same velocity
that you were dragging
it went when you let go?
So flings, scrolls,
all that stuff,
it really requires a velocity
based animation system instead.
You can do that
with the animators,
but it's really tedious.
It requires math.
Math is hard.
And so we've baked
in that capability
to this new Physics
Animation System that
is more natural, more
interactive, and more
interruptable
Because it was really
intended to work with that
user interactivity model.
Here's a small demo of this.
So as we're dragging
the top thing around,
the other two circles
are essentially
hinged to the top one through
springs that you defined.
And so they follow it in space.
They're not lockstep
following it,
but they're basically on
springs that are attached.
And they immediately benefit
from that interactivity
and that physics-based
notion of these springs.
So there's a talk on this
on Friday afternoon, all
about the new physics-based
animation stuff.
Please come to that if you
want to know more about that.
Architecture components.
This was mentioned
in the keynotes.
We thought that maybe
sometimes Android development
is a little bit harder
than it needs to be.
So we took a step back
and said, OK, what
are some of the major
problems that we should
take another run at
to try to simplify
this for app developers?
And a couple of those
that we've taken specific
runs at right now
or around lifecycle.
It is apparently kind of
hard to deal with the fact
that your activities
can die at any time
when you rotate the screen
or it goes in the background
or whatever.
And finding out exactly
what state you're in
can be a bit tedious.
It is an ongoing issue
that all app developers
need to deal with.
So we've taken another
approach to that
to make that much easier.
And in addition to
that, we've also
taken a look at persistence.
So you can issue raw SQL
now, and that's about all
you got on the system.
So we have a new way of doing
that builds on that capability
and makes it easier
and more powerful.
We're going to talk about
all of those this week.
We're going to have an
introduction to architecture
components, I would encourage
you to go to, this afternoon.
That's actually immediately
after this session.
And then tomorrow
morning, we're going
to have one on the
lifecycle problem
and how we've solved that.
And we're also going to have
one on persistence and offline.
And all of these are bits
that you can actually
try out in an earlier
release form already.
So check those out.
Hopefully it will make your
developer lives easier.
There are some behavior
changes, some of which
you're going to care
about more than others.
There have been some
changes to the behavior
of background applications,
in particular, location.
If you are running as a
background application,
you're only going to get course
grained location information.
All of these things are being
done not to make it harder,
but to make the
devices better, right?
If all applications have all
capabilities at all times,
and they can do whatever they
need to or want to at any time,
then essentially you're
going to run the battery down
because everybody's doing
too much work all the time.
So we're trying to be judicious
about which applications
actually need the
services at which times
so that we can make the
experience for the user much
better.
The experience for your
users much better as well.
So one of those is in location,
course grained information
when you're in the background.
Another one is wake locks.
We noticed that it was
common for an application
to go into a background state
and then into a cache state,
and it would have a
wake lock at the time.
And it would just
keep that wake lock,
and it would hold it
for a very long time.
And that really runs
the battery down.
So now, sometime after
you go into a cache state,
the wake lock is
automatically released
so that it doesn't
put the device
into that unseemly state.
And also there are
limits to execution
when you're running
in the background.
There have also been
changes to alert windows.
In particular,
there's this new type
of window called Type
Application Overlay.
If you are targeting the O SDK,
then this is the window type
that you must use if you
want to have an alert window
capability.
If you're on earlier releases,
obviously that didn't exist.
You're not going to use this.
Just know that whatever
window type you are using
is going to be layered under
one of these type application
overlay windows, because we
have a more clearly defined
layering policy now with that.
There is more information
about this afternoon
at 5 o'clock, Background
Check and Other Insights.
So please come to that
if you want to know
all the details about that.
And then, finally, we promised
to get back to this, didn't we?
DAN SANDLER: We did.
This is one more thing, right?
CHET HAASE: All right.
So we were going to talk
about this, and I think--
I mean, we have to have
a drumroll, don't we?
How about like a thigh roll?
Can we have a thigh roll?
[APPLAUSE]
CHET HAASE: All right.
DAN SANDLER: That sounds nice.
CHET HAASE: Unfortunately, I'm
looking at the timer on stage,
and I'm going to say
that O stands for--
AUDIENCE: Awww.
CHET HAASE: -- oh, no.
We're out of time.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]